Christ.
Where are you?
Heat. Heat.
So now
question.
Hey.
Okay, we're we're coming in in this
sunny afternoon. Where can I go?
>> Nowhere. Maybe if I don't see you.
Uh, welcome.
Welcome on a Super Bowl Sunday. Thank
you for coming and joining us early. Um,
and hopefully you can go out and watch
the Seahawks win.
Um, my name is Cath. My pronouns are
she, her, and we are so glad that you're
here this evening. Whether it's your
first time here or your first time in a
long time, we are happy that you chose
to be with us. And with that being said,
um some of you I know coming into a
church setting it can be a little
anxious.
So over in on that table we have what's
called an accessibility bucket for you.
There are fidget spinners, fidget
things, coloring sheets,
little head headphones and head earplugs
if you need them. So you can go pick
that up and then you drop it off on your
way out. Our
next state of the table will be next
Sunday at 3:30 here in the sanctuary.
that um is if you are a member of the
table or a regular table person that is
our family meeting
um that talks about the business items
the kids ministry the the different
ministries and also um our financial
even if you aren't a member of the table
and you are curious you are welcome to
be here so it's next Sunday at 3:30
for our family meetings.
Our game night that we had to be
postponed because of the snow again
incident that you can't tell we had
>> um will be February the 20th, Friday
night, same time. It'll be um 6:00 to
8:30. There will be a pasta bar set up
and if you would bring your favorite
game and dessert and join us in uh the
gymnasium area which is the the building
across the breezeway across the sidewalk
uh behind the church. We'd love to have
you on Friday night, February the 20th.
our Ash Wednesday service or um we we
are invited to join the Sax United
Methodist Church for the Ash Wednesday
service. Um the season of fasting and
prayer is known as Lyn and the the
church here has invited our members to
join them in their Ash Wednesday service
that is at 7 o'clock on February the
18th.
These candles
are a sign of the presence of Christ
among us.
Fully divine
and fully human.
Now we exit the kingdom of noise,
hurry and productivity.
Now we enter the kingdom of silence,
stillness and grace.
Now we enter sacred space. A space for
prayer, worship and adoration.
A space to encounter Christ. Revelation
of God.
Heart creation.
Allow the unforced rhythms of grace to
find you, to mend your heart.
May we all come.
Thank you, Cat. If you guys would stand
with me, we're gonna sing together
tonight. And um
we're going to start with um
sorry, there is a really lovely glare on
my screen that makes it very hard for me
to see what we're saying. Y'all, I
almost wore a hat tonight and now I know
that was Holy Spirit inspired and I
ignored him. So, how rude.
her. She He the spirit of the Lord was
talking to me. Okay, we're gonna start
with um a song that we've done many
times before, but last night as I was or
yesterday afternoon rather, while we
were gathered together to celebrate the
life of Vicky Ferris, some of you knew
her, I was just reminded of the gift
that we have in singing together. Um
that was something that really marked
like her time with the table was how
much she enjoyed our worship services
and uh and I've watched music be like
this soothing balm on her heart. So
tonight as we gather, I hope that
whatever is going on in our lives that
as we sing out, as we engage this time,
um as we receive these words and these
truths over our lives, I hope that it
can be like a healing bomb um that we
will receive them as promises, as hope
um as faith as we sing.
Where can we run?
Where can we hide?
You will not find
In the deepest of
the highest of heights,
your loving ches.
No matter where we've been,
no matter what we've done,
we cannot escape.
Oh,
and you will never see the air. You will
never see the end
of your
never see.
We will never see the end
of the world.
We pass.
We pass through the fire.
We pass through the flood.
You will be with us.
Though we walk through the valley of the
darkest of night,
your love will be
a light.
When we are a
and we are a world,
you will always be
and you will never see the air. We never
see the end
of your goodness.
We will never see the end. We will never
see the end
of your
And in our darkest hour
and on our hardest day,
we do not have to be afraid.
For you will never leave.
You will not forsake.
The promises that you have made
and in the darkest time
and on the hardest days.
We do not have to be afraid.
For you never leave
and you will not forsake.
promise is to you
and we will say let's sing it out cuz we
will never see the end. We will never
see the end
of the world.
We will never see the end. You will
never see the end
of the world.
All right, we're going to dismiss our
kids to go to their classes and your
teachers will meet you over by the
double doors.
Thank you, Maggie and Chloe.
and we're going to go ahead and
transition into the prayers of the
people. So you guys follow along on the
screens and we will read the parts that
are in red aloud together.
Jesus for this city of Saxi, Texas and
for every city and community and all who
live in them. We pray to you for the
good earth you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it. We
pray to you
for the old and the sick, for the widow
and the orphan, for the injured and
suffering. We pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute, for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them. We pray to you for the
vulnerable, the marginalized, and those
unjustly targeted for their gender,
sexuality, race, or other perceived
difference. We pray to you
for those experiencing loss, loneliness,
and disconnection. And for those
struggling with mental and emotional
health, we pray to you,
Lord. We know that you love us and that
you hear us. So we lift these names and
situations up to you.
For the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts, we pray to you
that they may have life and light,
healing and hope, peace and a deep sense
of your presence.
Amen.
You call me strong and courageous
when I don't feel like I
You could have turned me away, but you
chose me instead.
You say that I'm going.
You see the battle I'm facing. you.
You're in it with me. You're working
through me,
fighting for me. God is not against me.
You're in it with me.
You're working through me,
fighting for me. God is not against me.
I have a new
call.
I used to fight on my own but never
again.
I have a power that's greater
than the inside.
And I know the truth of the goel. You're
on my side. You're on my side.
You're in it with me.
You're working through me. You're
fighting for me. God is not against me.
You're in it with me.
You're working through me.
You're fighting for me. God is not
against me.
You're in it with me.
You're working through me.
You're fighting for me. God is not
against me.
You're in it with me.
You're working through me.
fighting for me. God is going to get me.
This is not my fight. You are my
defense.
You hold my life.
This is my confidence. You by my side.
You call me friend. You hold my life.
This is my confidence. This is my pride.
You are my defense.
You hold my life.
This is my confidence. You are by my
side. You've called me friend.
You hold my life.
This is my confidence.
You're in it with me.
You're working through me,
fighting for me. God is not against me.
You're in it with me.
You're working through me.
You're fighting for me. God is not
against me.
You are my defense.
You hold my life.
This is my confidence. You are my side.
You've called me friend. You hold my
life. This is my confidence.
You are my defense.
You hold my life.
This is my confidence. You are my sight.
You call me bra. You hold my life.
This is my company
against me
against me.
How
us
sing that one more time.
us.
How he loves us.
How he loves us so
he is for me.
Love's like a hurricane.
I am a tree
bending the knees. the weight of his
wind and mercy.
And all of a sudden,
I'm unaware of these affictions eclipsed
by glory.
And I realize just how beautiful you are
now. Your affection for
how he loves us.
Oh, how he loves us.
How he loves us.
>> How he loves us.
Oh, how he loves us.
How he loves us so
he loves us.
Oh, how he loves us.
Oh, how he loves
He loves us. Oh, how he loves us.
Oh, how he loves us.
Oh, how he loves.
Soon we are his portion. He is our
praise.
brought to redemption by the grace in
his eyes. He made one ocean.
Then heaven meets earth like this. Love
you with his and my heart turns brightly
inside of my chest. I don't have time to
maintain his rem
through
he loves us.
Oh, how he loves us.
Oh, how he loves Oh,
he loves us.
Oh, how he loves us.
Oh, how he loves
Hallelujah.
How he loves us so
he loves us.
How he loves us.
God, we trust
in your love that doesn't run out.
God, we sink ourselves in to an
unconditional love that saw us from the
beginning, that knows our story, that
has walked our shoes
and stays with us.
We believe in an Emmanuel, a God who is
with us,
not a God who is against us, not a God
of shame,
but one of love.
And despite the discouragement and the
pain that we experience, God, we also
hold on to the hope that we find in
Jesus.
Someone who would lay their life down on
behalf of ours.
Someone who saw the creation and said it
is good.
God, we gather together and we celebrate
that life that we find in you.
Help us to trust him.
Help us to see it in our darkest hour on
our hardest day to know that we are not
alone.
To know that we are fought for,
that we are celebrated and we are loved.
It's in Jesus name that we pray.
Amen.
Would you guys turn to the person on
your right and left and say the peace of
Christ be with you and then you may be
seated and Brett will start our message.
Well,
grace and peace. It is uh it's good to
be with you all. So, so good. And uh my
name is Brett. Pronouns he him. And uh
yeah, a joy joy to welcome you into this
space. And as always, that includes
those joining us online. You're not
forgotten. And uh don't forget to get
your communion elements for later in the
service. We'd love if you could kind of
join in uh with us in that that
practice. And uh yeah, just want to
welcome you all. And as always, that
also um includes anyone here who's new.
Thank you for uh being here. I know it
can take a lot of courage to come
through those double doors into a church
space, especially depending on church
history. And um you know, it's pretty
rare the person who walks through our
doors and is has nothing but fond
memories of churches and uh so it can be
can kind of be a lot. So, thank you for
for being here with us. So, we are in uh
a series right now. This part four of
our series titled No Fear in Love, a
study of First John. We're basically
taking five weeks to just uh kind of
take at least we can't like really cover
the whole I mean it could take a year to
go through like every verse, you know,
so we're kind of just choosing like five
kind of key passages from um various
chapters and kind of working our way
through it. And uh so the title of our
message today is healing within healing
the world. And our passage we're into
chapter 3. So it's 1 John 3 right there
at the beginning verses 1-2. And it
reads, "See what great love the father
has lavished on us, that we should be
called children of God, and that is what
we are." The reason the world does not
know us is that it did not know him,
dear friends. Now, we are children of
God, and what we will be has not yet
been made known. But we know that when
Christ appears, we shall be like him,
for we shall see him as he is.
We're going to get kind of more into the
language like children of God and all
that later in the message. We're going
to start is uh right there at the kind
of end of of verse um verse one that
says, "The reason the world does not
know us is that it did not know him." As
we spoke about last week, the language
here of the world, it doesn't mean like
creation or the body or uh you know
having fun. Uh it's not not really about
that. Instead uh the world kind of
refers to the I would say the kind of
relational dynamics born from human egos
you So maybe the better phrase here is
like the ways of the world or the system
of the the world and this is what you
know kind of trips us up and it's you
know I would say it's a lot of human
culture not everything of of human
culture although it does feel like the
further human culture kind of goes you
know uh it's like I kind of feel like
the worse it gets in way or like the
more egoic and kind of crazy I don't
know but uh maybe that's just some sort
of bias in myself but you know in
essence it's kind of you know the the
world it's like you you know, it's it's
all that wanting and grasping and
clinging and uh showboating and the the
ego and all of its wild uh kind of
insecurity. And it's strange the way
that manifests like it can come out in a
a kind of um intense kind of self
argrandisement, you know, a kind of
narcissism, you know, like this belief
of like I am the greatest, I am the
best, I'm the, you know, um or that same
insecurity can kind of come out as I'm
the worst, I'm you know, I'm trash, I'm
it's I mean I can like swing between
these in like the same day, you know,
it's like my ego is wild and uh this is,
you know, it's this is how it is. um
that the ego and all of its kind of
climbing and stockpiling, you know, I
mean, anything, not even just physical
good, you know, money or um accolades,
uh attention,
you know, the the applause of people or
the crowd. The uh the writer Robert
Quillin um put it this way. I think this
is a good summary of egos and maybe it's
specific American type. He says this,
"Americanism, using money you haven't
earned to buy things you don't need to
impress people you don't like." Maybe
you've heard that one. Or uh there's
here's the modern kind of internet
version of that. I couldn't find who
actually said this first, but it's we
post content that isn't ours for likes
that aren't real to impress people we
don't know. You know, that's there you
go. That's You're wondering like what is
always talking about ego like There you
have it. You know, it's kind of this is
bizarre. And uh you know the thing is
it's this kind of collective you know
insanity but man it's it's deep in us
you know and what that means is we can
and we do you know kind of you know
convert or ch you know walk the aisle
and choose to follow Christ or get
baptized or you know we take these steps
and that's beautiful and good but the
trick is that egoic mind that would be
kind of the opposite of the mind of
Christ you know um that egoic mind
that's still that's in us, you know what
I mean? And that has to um kind of get
processed, you know, and it's not so
easily uprooted. If the uh kind of the
egoic ways of the world in the way of
Christ were like a vin diagram, it would
just be like two circles that just like
never meet. They're just kind of just
like right here just kind of
and I think this is why
Christ, you know, if you've read the
Gospels, uh why he has been continues to
be such a completely compelling figure.
Uh, I mean, just seems like there's just
no ego in the man, you know, and but
it's also why he's this kind of a bit of
like an enigma, a a riddle, a mystery uh
to us, right? Which ties back in with
John's message around like the world
just didn't recognize him. Just did not
know what to do with him, you know? I
mean, like the disciples spent their
whole time trying to get him to run for
office. You know what I mean? Like just
you should be a king. You'd make a
freaking great king. And of course, they
were they were, you know what I mean?
like he would have been a great king,
you know, but he's like, "Look, I've got
a a different calling, you know what I
mean?" And uh which we'll kind of get to
in a moment. So, Ramon Panachar um talks
about this really beautifully. He wrote
this wonderful work of theology called
Chrisphan. Chrisphanie, the fullness of
man. It's a bit academic, but it's like
just an incredible
kind of going in and out. Can I I'm
gonna go ahead and snag the uh this one
so I don't
have to worry about that.
There we go. Um, so Ramon Panagar, this
is Chrisphony, the fullness of man. And
he's here in this passage, he's
reflecting on kind of the end of the
life of Christ. And he put it this way.
He said, Jesus of Nazareth is about to
leave us.
He neither lays foundations for anything
nor does he initiate any religion.
He does not play the role of a teacher,
a title that he does not like. You'll
remember moments where even like he
didn't even like the language of like
leader which is interesting because like
churches you know we still like use that
language but he Jesus he wasn't big on
it like they're like oh you're our
leader and he was like don't call me
leader in fact don't don't any of you
call each other leader you know it's a
he's just very again very non-egoic in
this way. Um so he continues you know a
title that he does not like his time has
arrived
and he leaves after accomplishing his
mission which was not it seems and this
we must acknowledge a great success.
It's an interesting little ending there.
What does he mean Christ? How could
Christ not be a great success? Well,
again, he's thinking from this kind of
the ways of the world, right? So, right,
Christ is he's crucified, he's
resurrected, he's ascended, and uh
leaves behind, you know, a hundred or so
followers, just a tiny fledgling little
community, probably not too different
than like the table, you know, I mean,
just a small little community. And uh,
you know, again, from the kind of eyes
of the world, it's just kind of like, I
don't know, it's like not that
impressive, Jesus. You know, you spent
quite a few years here. you think you
could do better being the son of God and
all, you know, uh but it was just this
little this little community and uh I
think knowing Christ, you know, and his
giftings and such, you would think,
well, come on. It could have been so
much bigger,
grander, more effective, you know what I
mean? Like, right? Come on, Jesus. He
just had no interest in this. I mean,
just refused to play along.
Why?
Again, this is Panachar writing. Now
he's writing from the first person
perspective of Christ. This is a little
bit later in the book. You divine
mystery
who my people call father, you are truly
the direct origin.
He generates what I am.
You are the source from whom I descend.
I feel your life passes through me. That
my life does not come from myself but
from a fountain that not only gives me
life in general but also the words, the
ideas, the inspiration, everything that
I am. And here's the key line.
Everything that I say is always
something I have heard.
That's the key, right? Why doesn't
Christ just, you know, do something
bigger, effect, more effective, more
grand, more impressive, more Why?
Because he's obeying the voice,
the voice of the one he called father.
Right? There's echoes here of uh John
chapter 5 in John chapter 12, which I
reference often. You know, Jesus said,
"I don't say anything. I don't say
anything except what I hear the father
saying. I don't do anything except what
I see the father doing."
Right? All right. So, while ego says
make it bigger, make it grander, make it
impressive. You know, you your life,
they they are what you make it what you
what you force it to be, Christ says no,
no, no, no, no, no, no. My life's
actually not my own.
All my words, my inspiration, everything
I say and do and sense, I actually
receive it. I receive it. So, you know,
what does this mean for us, for kind of
our our own life? Well, I think you
know, most Christians are fairly content
to say, um, you know, good for Jesus.
Like, this is so
it's so good for him. I've been watching
Shitz Creek again, so that's I just this
is so good for you. I just love it for
you. You know, it's one of the
characters. Um, so good for you, Jesus.
you know, and uh
but of course, you know, we kind of say
like, well, that's great for him, but
he's the son of God, you know, and so
I'm going to kind of leave that to him.
I've got honestly a life and I got to
get back to that and keeps me busy and
so I'm just going to do that and kind of
leave all this other stuff, you know,
leave it to uh to Jesus.
uh when of course the thing is the
invitation to disciplehip right is to do
as Jesus did which which doesn't mean a
kind of weird like a kind of a slavish
like uh too literal imitation like we
also must become carpenters and travel
around as itinerate preachers you know
there's a kind of over-the-topness of an
imitation of Jesus that's not what it's
about it's it's a um instead well it's
imitating
this kind of deep surrendering
you
this egoic me that I don't know about
you, but I got plans. I love plans. My
plans, you know, and there's something
so hard about this kind of surrender and
okay, I don't want to say anything
except what I hear the father saying,
what the spirit's whispering me to say.
I don't want to do anything except
exactly what God would will me, you
know, to do. there's there's this um
kind of heart that's wanting longing to
become love and that's that's the the
disciplehip you know process that we're
all invited into. So here's Panakar
again uh but now he shifts to us. So he
says this if I cling and then just
notice all the things he lists here. I
don't know about you the first time I
read this I was like oh god this cuts so
deep. If I cling to my life, to my ego,
to my mission, to my task, to my ideal,
or even worse, to my goods, to my
family, to people, to the world, if I do
not let everything go, if I do not
renounce every desire to prolong my
life, even though I call it immortality,
and insist on constructing monuments to
my creation, and aspire to control all
that has cost me so much toil to
produce, so that it might not all get
lost.
Life will be suffocated.
I love here this panic there is echoing
the words of Christ, right? Where if we
grasp our life, what happens? We
actually paradoxically lose it. But if
we let it go, we surrender. Then we gain
it. We we gain we end up gaining life,
joy, peace, happiness, and so on. Again,
this only makes kind of sense though
from the perspective of like the
spiritual life, right? Not the kind of
egoic successoriented materialistic
world. And this is why John writes, "The
reason the world does not know us
is that it did not know him." Or maybe I
should add, maybe John was being
idealistic. Um the reason the world
should not know us, but often does. You
know, I mean, maybe the the reason the
world does recognize us is because we
just look like the world in so many way.
You know what I mean? It's like um this
is kind of the challenge, you know, but
at at our best, the reason the world
doesn't recognize us, doesn't get us,
you know, is because it for the same
reason it did not know Jesus, right? In
other words, you really do kind of have
to decide here like what are what's your
life going to be about? You know, what
are what are we prioritizing here? Are
we going to spend our life kind of um
perfecting the self
or will we surrender and transcend
oursel? See the way of the world is
perfecting the self more cool
experiences, more accolades, more likes
on Insta, more promotions, more money,
more vacations, more of the esteem of
others, right? And here's the trick.
even much of what passes for kind of
Christianity
can actually if it's just in this kind
of egoic vein it just ends up being more
self you know I mean the kind of
obsession with like my unique theology
you know my beliefs my doctrines uh my
Bible knowledge uh my um inagram number
spiritual gifts my spiritual experience
experiences uh my spiritual practices
right all of these things by which I am
building my spiritual self you know you
can see where this like very cleverly
kind of gets like oh slightly off off
track where in essence it's just more of
kind of building up myself instead of
this kind of deeper
you know kind of surrendering
uh type type process because the way of
the spirit the way of Christ it's always
the way of the cross you know it's
always the surrender of the self
dissolving transcending the egoic me so
that it's no longer I who live but
Christ who lives in me
now um I was thinking about this message
up to this point as I was writing I was
thinking of us you know and here's the
trick this is you you all are very
challenging group to preach to um
honestly it's a compliment you're all
like very beautiful souls in a lot of
ways and there's Honestly, if I'm being
honest, um you're not uh I don't I don't
sense a lot of people are like, "Yeah,
money."
You know what I mean? Like that's my
life. Money. I don't know. Like just
different cultures, different places
have their struggles, their thing, you
know what I mean? the ways the ego kind
of manifests, you know, I mean, in that
kind of culture or place, you know, and
uh and so, you know, that's not really I
don't think maybe for some of you maybe
that's a part of it, you know, but on
the whole I don't really get that vibe.
Um, also I would say kind of being a
more, you know, uh, progressive
Christian congregation, um, I don't
think I don't think many of us are like
really rooting our kind of egos in
spiritual practices and such. um you
know maybe years down the road as we all
engage that more maybe that will become
more of a thing. Uh but again, I don't
know. I don't really necessarily think
of that or see that, you know. So, I was
kind of thinking like what does this
look like for us, you know, like what's
what's kind of our struggle? Because I
think as I've spoken about before, it's
always easy to see in others, you know
what I mean? Like I can tell you what
like all the other churches are
struggling with, you know, and their
ways their ego manifest, but it is it's
quite hard to kind of see yourself see
your own community and you know, think
in these ways. So um I was kind of
reflecting on this and I was thinking
you know I think um one way it manifests
is in the a kind of um intense um at
times it can be anger at times fear at
times a kind of controlling a kind of
anxiety um over the state of the world.
you know, a kind of slow building almost
a rage, you know, at the we can see the
injustice and the pain. I mean, and
really not just the world in general,
but like even the United States um in
particular right now. I mean, I had this
moment actually even just this
afternoon, I was like catching up on
news like many of you. I I kind of um
try to space it out, you know? I mean, I
can't do every hour every day. So, I
kind of have my moments to check in and
see, all right, what's going horribly
now, you know? And uh and it was just I
was reading, you know, up on Minneapolis
and everything going on there and just
like just a disaster, you know what I
mean? And it's just so I don't know,
it's just you get, you know, all the
emotions and these reactions and I was
no doubt. I mean, it's hilarious. I was
about to preach this sermon, but I was
like a few seconds away from just doing
like y'all know from time to time I get
on trouble in trouble for Facebook and
posting. I kind of pick my spots, but
you know, I come out and then just stir
up a bit nest. I almost did it again,
you know, just like um and to be clear,
I think the spirit at times leads in
that way. You know what I mean? So, I'm
not trying to put that down, but it's
it's always tricky process for me to
kind of discern, well, again, I only
want to say what I sense the father
saying. I only, you know what I mean?
And is this what's going on here? So, I
was thinking, you know, how does this
play out? Um, and one of the phrases
that I think can kind of capture this
this despair, you know, is the
statement, everything is on fire.
Have you uh maybe said that or heard it
or I've definitely said it, you know?
It's like, "How are you doing?" "Oh,
great. Everything's on fire." You know
what I mean? Like the the culture, the
the the government, the you know, I
mean, the society, the church, there I
mean it's fine. Everything is on fire,
you know? And um
I think the trick is, you know,
in that kind of moment,
I think it it can feel like a certain
nobility. You know what I mean? And uh
when actually at times ego can get in
there and push us towards this despair
and this rage where we end up so
reactionary against the very people that
we're LIKE YOU SHOULD BE MORE LOVING.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN? AND WE'RE KIND OF
LIKE AND THEY'RE LIKE DON'T LOOK SO
loving to me. You know what I mean? And
it's um it's very hard. It's just so
tricky to walk this out. It reminds me a
bit of the a story by the spiritual
writer Sylvia Bourstein. She wrote this
book titled Don't Just Do Something, Sit
There,
which kind of advocated for a lot of
what I've been naming this kind of a
kind of contemplative approach, you
know, to life and spiritual practice and
such. And so she said she did this whole
multi-ity book tour where she said, but
her she had one interview that was like
very memorable radio interview. the host
had her on and but before they started
the interview um the host kind of read
all of the day news headlines naming you
know all of the horrible stuff we've
been talking about just all sorts of
horrible tragedies and pain and you know
all this and uh then she transitioned to
Borstein in her first question she said
well you've heard all that I've been
telling my listeners it's up to them to
make a difference to go off city hall to
talk to your legislators to get on
school boards to make a And yet you
Sylvia Bourstein, you're telling people
don't just do something. Sit there. What
do you have to say for yourself?
And uh Sylvia, she responded this way.
She said, "I could not agree with you
more. Absolutely. Each of us is
obligated to make a difference, to act
when we see something that needs to be
done. I'm suggesting that it is valuable
to be still for long enough to figure
out what would be the most helpful thing
to do."
You know, I think there's that's back to
that discerning. I got to discern. I've
got to hear the spirit. What's the
spirit leading me to say and do? And uh
I I think you know, she's naming here
this kind of contemplative practice
helps us kind of put in therapy speak.
It would be kind of a respond rather
than react. I think that's good and
essential. But I want to go even further
and say it's not just about that. There
is, I think, an even deeper work that
Christ is inviting us into here. And and
I think it's so important for those
those of us kind of working for a kind
of societal and communal, you know,
healing and hoping for that for others
um to make sure that we're on the path
to find that kind of inner healing
ourselves.
It's a bit like um if there was like a
doctor who had the very disease that
they were trying to heal others from.
And so even as they went around trying
to heal everyone else, they didn't
realize that they were infecting them
over and over again. You know what I
mean? That's kind of the paradox of the
the trick of what we're doing. Like we
talked about early on this this ego,
it's in me, too. You know what I mean?
And uh
and so we have to allow Christ to start
to heal
this stuff in us. Tiknahan, the monk,
the peace activist, he put it this way.
is that if we're at war with our
parents, our family, our society, our
church, uh there's probably a war going
on inside us also. So the most basic
work for peace is to return to ourselves
and create harmony among the elements
within us, our feelings, our
perceptions, our mental states. That's
why the practice of meditation looking
deeply is so important.
This um I think this is why I emphasize
so much kind of contemplative practice
and identity work. you know, knowing who
I am, knowing that I'm God's beloved.
So, I can come to that or we all can
come to that kind of settled place and
then speak and act from that place of
kind of wholeness and healing
um so that we can be a voice for peace
in this world and really our presence
can be a healing presence in the world.
Uh as John writes coming back, see what
great love the father has lavished on us
that we should be called children of God
and that is what we are.
See we must first become rooted in our
belovedness
and from that place we speak we act. I
want to uh to close with this poem. This
is from um Wendel Barry. It's one of
those kind of works that I think it
speaks to kind of the despair of the
moment and the the kind of contemplative
response. And I I'll close out with
this. He says, "When despair for the
world grows in me and I wake in the
night at the least sound
in fear of what my life and my
children's lives may be, I go and lie
down where the wood drake rests in his
beauty on the water in the great heron
feeds. I come into the peace of wild
things who do not tax their lives with
forethought of grief.
I come into the presence of still water
and I feel above me the day blind stars
waiting with their light. For a time I
rest in the grace of the world and am
free.
I think that's the invitation of Jesus
Christ to all of us. But what Barry kind
of speaks of here is this, you know,
this kind of a fleeting experience. you
know, where you can get away to nature,
you can have those maybe just a little
moment and find some peace. Um, I think
actually the what Christ is inviting us
into is a kind of starting to live from
that state of grace or instead of
visiting it on occasion, you know,
instead it kind of becomes the very
roots of our soul
where we start to know our belovedness.
We know the belovedness of all things
and all people even though the world
would have us call enemies. We know
they're beloved of God, too. And from
that place, our speech, our actions can
leave a lasting impact of peace on this
world.
In the name of the Father, the Son, and
the Holy Spirit. Amen.
So as we uh
gather for communion
um we get to participate again in that
that practice of receiving the very uh
body and blood of Jesus Christ. And uh
so as the way we're going to kind of go
about communion tonight is we're just
going to kind of row by row here. We'll
start here not at the front second row.
And uh we'll just form a line right here
in the middle. And uh you know, as one
row finishes, the next one can get up
and uh and jump in. The uh the red is
wine, the white is grape juice. You can
go ahead and partake of the elements
whenever you'd like. So some folks like
to come and kneel, others partake
immediately, some like to return to
their chair, just however you want to
take, you can you can uh do that. And
finally, we practice what's called an
open table. So if you're here tonight,
you want to participate, then you're
you're welcome to do that. So this is
the table, not of the church, but of the
Lord. And it's made ready for those who
love him and for those who want to love
him more. So come. You who have much
faith and you who have little. You who
have been here often and you who have
not been here long. You who have tried
to follow and you who have failed. Come.
Come. Because it's the Lord Jesus
himself who invites you. And it's his
will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here. Come to the table.
Would
you guys stand with us as we close out
um with this song that we learned
earlier? And I just want to hold on to
these these words as we go into our week
um remembering that that is for us, that
he is with us,
and take that as a promise that we can
hold on to, as we can sink ourselves
into as we face what's ahead this week.
This is not my fight. You are my
defense.
You are my life. This is my confidence.
You're my side. You called me friend.
You hold my life.
This is my confidence. This is not my
fight. You are my defense.
You hold my life. This is my confidence.
You are by my side. You have called me
friend. You hold my life.
This is my confidence.
This is my
in it with me.
Fighting for me. God is not against me.
You're in it with me.
You're working through me.
You're fighting for me. God is not
against me.
Thank you so much for joining us this
evening.
If you are visiting, we would love for
you to fill out uh a card at the table
on your way out, a little uh visitors
card, or you can scan the QR code uh and
fill it out online.
Um generosity is a key aspect of
adoration and worship. to give
financially, you can scan the QR code
and you can do that online as well.
If you call the table home and you would
like to be a part of a ministry team, we
have several ministry teams that you can
choose from. We have our children's
ministry. We have our worship team
ministry. We have our AV team. We have
our host team, which I like to call the
little elves that set up and have it all
ready for you. Um, you can scan the QR
code, go to the um the table at the
tabletx.org
for more information and we would love
to have you.
Now, I'd like to send you out with this
benediction. You may hold your hands out
in a posture to receive or just open
your heart.
You are a child of God.
This is true on your best day
and this is true on your worst day.
So as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows,
go
with the assurance
that you are loved,
that you are worthy,
and that you are accepted
just as you are.
And go
filled with God's Holy Spirit.
and extend these same gifts to all of
those that you come in contact with.
Be blessed. Have a great week and we
will see you back here next week at 3:30
for the state of the table.
Good night.
You're in it with me. You're working
through me,
fighting for me. God is not against me.
You're in it with me.
You're working through me. You're
fighting for me. God is not against me.
You're in it with me.
You're working through me. You're
fighting for me. God is not against me.
You're in it with me. You're working
through me.
But holy God is against me.